liebes tagebuch am freitagabend war ich
auf dem weihnachtsmarkt und habe dort
einen glühwein getrunken
danach sind wir zu der pub gegangen der
laden sieht wirklich sehr schön aus und
man kann dort sogar sein eigenes bier
zapfen
aber robert hat nur schaum bekommen und
marx hat einen kleinen bürger bekommen
china hat uns ein lustiges bild von
thomas mit einem hut gezeigt zu hause
habe ich dann meinen kandierten
weintrauben gegessen sie haben aber gar
nicht geschmeckt
vor dem schlafen habe ich noch nicht
alles gespielt und den stil in horb muss
film geschaut
am samstag habe ich mein fünftes türchen
aufgemacht
es war schokolade am sonntag war dann
auch schon nikolaus es habe das sechste
türchen aufgemacht
es war schokolade
und ein gutschein ich habe vom nikolaus
ein feuerzangenbowle set bekommen und
später habe ich mit meiner freundin
zimtsterne gebracht ganz viele zum
stehen
dann haben wir richtige feuerzangenbowle
deshalb mussten wir aber trotzdem handy
auch rausschmeißen
die können sich nämlich an dem feuer
verbrennen und an den hier auch manchmal
sieht henry aus wie ein hund
manchmal versucht gomez ihm zu helfen
und manchmal fange ich einfach an zu
sehen
ich glaube etwas später hatte henry
bauschmerzen
also habe ich ihn so lange gestreichelt
wie es wollte
danach habe ich das siebte türchen von
einem adventskalender aufgemacht es war
schokolade drin
dann haben meine katzen die letzten
ruhigen minuten genossen denn es zog ein
sturm auf und der sturm hieß mirella
lima
untersucht
und dennoch viel größere sturm bald
kennen
ja
der bremer
wir haben bis 5 uhr morgens gedreht
damit wir auch für jeden ein video haben
und dann bin ich um 1 auf gestanden
ende